this is climate activist lissy green's
eighth day on hunger strike
the 15 year old from windsor is having
herbal tea and water
and is being supervised by her mum laura
she's demanding a u-turn on the
government's refusal to block plans for
a new coal mine
hundreds of miles away in cumbria it's
not nice to be constantly hungry it's
not nice
to struggle with concentration and it's
not nice to feel dizzy and have
headaches
would you say to people who live locally
in cumbria who say that they need the
jobs
then i would say it's the responsibility
of the government to look after those
people and create
jobs that are in line with the
government's emissions targets yeah i'm
really struggling to sleep i didn't even
i forgot about that but it's actually
been
affected my sleep a lot lissy is on a
hunger strike with another climate
activist
17 year old elijah mackenzie jackson
both teenagers say they will stop
before they need medical help i'm
currently feeling really really tired
shaky and ill
and it's really really really difficult
at the moment um but one thing we need
to remember
is the nhs is under severe pressure due
to coronavirus so i wouldn't want to
impact
that at all the burning of fossil fuels
like
coal contributes to climate change
environmentalists say if the government
is serious about its net zero promises
there should be no new coal mines in the
uk
cumbria county council has given
planning permission
for an offshore mine and processing
plant to
supply coal for steel production
democratically the local authorities
have decided to approve and not once but
three occasions
so you know it really is time for for
people to
understand that the the arguments have
been hard
um it's time for the mind to just press
ahead and bring the
the benefits the much needed benefits
that this mind will bring into west
cumbria
the ministry of housing communities and
local governments said the planning
application is a local issue
the teenagers say the emissions from the
cumbrian mine
are a global problem when the world is
facing
a climate emergency lisa holland sky
news